[Music]
my name is Esteban I'm the lead of the
profiling sin and the studio and today
I'm gonna show you all the new features
we have in Android studio 3.2 and some
of the features that we launched in
under to do 3.1 in the profilers right
so I'm gonna be doing a demo for most of
the session but just in case you haven't
seen the profilers before just just to
get an idea how many of you have used
the profilers you know okay that's great
well I was gonna explain that we have
these profilers to you but most of you
have seen them but we have a new
profiler that I'm gonna be introducing
today that is the energy profiler as you
know we have the monitors that show you
live telemetry from the app we have a
CPU network memory and the new energy
profiler and you can dive in into any of
those and for example inspect your
network requests see where you made the
request from code see what you actually
downloaded what was sent you can also
dive in into the memory profiler see the
breakdown of the memory see how many
objects you have allocated where you
located them you can also dive into the
CPU profiler I'm gonna be showing some
new cool features that we added there in
3.2 specifically systrace again I'm
gonna ask the question how many of you
have used this trace before okay cool
now systrace is we started with the
first steps of integrating sisters into
the Android studio CPU profiler I'm
gonna be demoing that in a few moments
and last but not least is the new energy
profiler that will guide you in finding
problems in your app that could lead to
energy profiling energy issues I took
more about that at the end of the
session
and with that that's it that's all this
lights and a half so I'm gonna move to
the demo now and I have to make a
disclaimer so all the features that I'm
gonna be demoing today are in under
studio 3.2 canary and there is a reason
why they are not in the stable release
yet so we might be in for a bumpy ride
but I wanted to show you what we have
and you know if it crashes we just keep
it between us and people watching on
YouTube and that's it all right so I
brought last week this clock app it's a
simple clock app that has the clock it
has a stopwatch that you can click does
something and it has a timer and I want
to profile it with you guys so let's
first start with Network profiler so
this app has a lot of features than a
clock app should not have for example in
its internet access it needs to access
location it has a lot of things so we
can demo this so please do not write the
clock up like this so one of the
features it has is you can change the
background so if the internet connection
is good enough this thing is gonna start
downloading some images right now there
we go
you can dive in into the network
profiler you surely have seen this
before and you can see all the network
requests that have been done you can
click on them and see the actual payload
something new that was added in 3.1 is
the ability for us to see what we send
not just what we receive but we can say
the payload or the custom headers that
we use in this case I have one custom
header that says Doble Oak there is
another new feature in 3.14 the network
of filer and that is the threads view so
as you see here we show you the requests
in a timeline but if you choose thread
view what you can see
on which thread this is and let me close
this so you have more space there we go
so you can see each request on which
thread it was made and if we have more
like this I'm using a standard
synchronous task which uses a default
executor that will run them sequentially
and you can see them and if they were
reusing the same thread you can see them
to you but if in your app you have more
complex threading with Network requests
you can use this view to see what's
going on so those are the two new
features on the network profiler that we
added in 3.1 and now I'm gonna move to
the memory profiler let me go to the
live session if you have seen this view
before we split up how much memory you
are using into different components but
we also show you the number of objects
you have allocated if you are profiling
on an Android or your phone or newer we
have and this is this is super cool we
have a feature called live a location
tracking remember back in the back in
the day was probably last year when you
had to do a location tracking you had to
click on a button to record the
locations and then you would see them
well if we wanted to know what happened
here we can see that the object line is
going up as being garbage collections
going up as being garbage collected just
if you want to see what's happening just
select a range and we will have the
information of every single object that
was allocated there at which time it was
allocated and where in your code
it was allocated and you can slide this
window and you can see this thing
changing so if I slide it over a garbage
collection period you will see which
objects were Delocated let me close this
window there we go we can see that there
was a lot of strings yeah located so we
can start actually having a look at this
app and see how bad it is written for
example if I select this and I want to
see what was located I can see that
there were a lot of strings allocated I
can click on any one of those
where I a located them and I allocated
them inside an on draw this is not a
good idea if you have a custom view and
you allocate a lot of strings there but
things will happen and we'll see more
about that through the CPU profiler but
this is already starting to tell us
signals about what my app is doing wrong
another new thing that we added in 3.2
is the ability to see j'ni global
references this is very important
because a lot of memory leaks occur
because one j9 global reference is
created and we don't know when we
created it and we don't know where it is
so when you select a range what I have
here in my app every time I download an
image I run a filter through it in C++
to darken it so the font can be seen and
I have a global reference there and I
hope I didn't I did right right so we
have a special key which we call the
Jana here that when you select it you
can see all the global references that
existed in this range of time in this
case I have this inter ray and I know I
created one but it should have been gone
so let me go live here and select range
and here it is this is my global this is
every image that I downloaded I still
holding a gene a global reference to it
and I can actually navigate to the c++
line of code where i created a global
reference i never let go so i hope this
is useful to track down problems with
global references in j9 and one more
thing you probably have been seeing all
the time on the left that we have a new
panel called the sessions panel well now
we allow you to see previous sessions
that you have been profiled so you can
navigate back and compare previous runs
so if you're working on optimizing your
app so what did I change you can go back
and see if your sessions will at the end
of the demo hopefully we can go back and
see what what we optimized and what
happened but that opened the door for us
to do things like this now
can import a file I'm gonna import hip
them and this hip them is being imported
directly into the new profilers and it
creates what we call it fake session for
it and you can analyze the hip them as
you are used to in the profilers you can
also import traces for CPU and
everything we can export we can import
too so that's pretty handy on this is
new in 3.2 and this is what I wanted to
show for memory and now we're gonna go
to CPU and spend most time there right
all right this is the live session and
I'm gonna show you one feature that you
have alright so one thing that we wanted
to add was the ability to profile since
the beginning so as if you've used the
profile is you notice that if you want
to profile your app startup you have to
quickly go to CPU profiler and click
record so you can see what's happening
well in three point two what you can do
is if you go to the profiling tab we
have a an option that says start
recording a method trace on startup so I
have this ticked you can choose the
configuration that you want in this case
I'm gonna use sample java configuration
and I'm gonna rerun the app
now you can see that they are restarted
the profilers took me directly to the
CPU profiler and there is already a
capture in progress from the very
beginning of the app so I'm gonna stop
it now and we're gonna investigate what
happened there take a few seconds to get
the data cool I don't know if you can
see the resolution on that screen but
let's have a look and see that I'm gonna
select the very beginning of the app in
fact you can see that the capture
started even before our telemetry could
start getting data from the app right
our telemetry started here but they have
started before and we can see the data
and if we keep zooming in there you can
see the first uncreate of my main
activity and even before that we can see
when all the exits were lowered and the
very very beginning of your app so with
this mechanism you can profile from the
very beginning optimize the startup time
of your app cool but let's have a look
at this capture and see if those strings
we saw before are actually causing some
problems one of my favorite views in the
CPU profiler is the flame chart the
flame chart aggregates all the coal
stacks that have the same beginning so
you can see it's basically the top-down
tree but in a visual way and you can see
that one of the biggest things is my own
draw the way I wrote this app is on
every frame I'm rendering everything
again that's not a good way of doing it
but it's a really good example for the
profilers so you can see that I'm
rendering and there is a lot of things
at the top that have to do with the
string formatting and this could be the
source of our string problem that we saw
before so it's another symptom that your
app is is not doing well one thing that
I always say about our profilers is that
we cannot really tell you what's wrong
in your app we can only tell you what
your app is doing and then it's up to
you
to say oh I didn't expect this to happen
because as you can see my app looks fine
but under the hood is not so let's say
you have a bug on a label that you put
wrong and it's in a different position
you rather your app you see there
they're always wrong I need to fix this
but if you have something like a
performance issue wrong you won't see it
you won't see it until even we talk
about battery later and you will see it
in the field right so we want our
profilers to be another window to your
app so that you can run your app while
seeing their profilers and then you see
the problems there because something
that you did not expect start showing
out like me doing a lot of string
formatting inside an entre code
cool so let's go to the code what I have
my so I have my own draw and I have a
function called draw time where I draw
the time on my app and I have a wrote a
function called draw time string that
uses string formatting to draw the time
and it's probably not a good idea
so that's a coincidence I have another
function that writes that draws the time
without using strings are we gonna try
oh before we do that let me show you one
thing that we have here so how many of
you are familiar with this line of code
trace dot begin section cool so what
this line does and together with the end
section they will create a see stress
event that you can use systrace to see
so before I make my optimization I'm
gonna show you what happens if i take a
capture using the system trace method so
this is running systrace under the hood
and you don't have to go to the python
script anymore and get it and then get
it back on your own the HTML view we
will instead show it to you right here
in our app in under studio
remember what I mentioned about the
bumpy ride
this is it Yugi
let me restart the emulator and we'll do
it again
there we go please please try this at
home file bugs we will fix them and when
we get this table these issues will be
all sorted out there we go I'm gonna go
to the CPU profiler and use CSUN trace
second time's the charm okay so we have
systems right here let me select and
zoom into the selection cool one thing
that you notice here that first of all
we have a new section there there called
the colonel section where we show you
all the CPUs and if you pay close
attention
we rerender all this thread information
getting all the data from systrace so
before the sprint information we get
sampling the proc file system so it's
not very accurate but as soon as you
take a systrace capture you can see
exactly where what your thread is doing
at every moment
and more than that if I select one of
those we highlight above on which CPU
your thread is being scheduled so you
can look at thread contention or other
things that are kicking you out of the
CPU there is a fundamental difference in
the way we show sisters here with the
way you see it in the HTML view here we
focus on your app so everything here
that is highlighted green even the dark
green is just your app you can still go
and see the other events and see what
it's taking is if you or why you're
being kicked out but we focus on your
app we show you the threads of your app
so you don't have to navigate that
gigantic HTML page and we use all the
other things that you know about all the
other captures we use them for systrace
for example flame chart or a top-down
view so let me zoom in the moment in
time there we can see our frames so I
have here let me zoom in more and choose
actually my main thread there we go so
we can see the choreographer do frame
and further down we can see the ondraw
on my custom component and we can see
the draw time remember in the code let
me go back to the code and show you in
the raw time we have a draw time around
the section around my time string and
you can see that I'm rendering it three
times
one for every section of my app and we
can quickly see how long each one of
those is taking right so I'm taking 38
milliseconds to render a frame if you
want your app to render 60 frames per
second you'd have to render under 17
each friend milliseconds now I'm Way
over that in fact one of my calls to
draw time is taking 11 milliseconds so
my app is not doing well it looked okay
but imagine you ship this and people
complain this is one of the things that
I was mentioning about you get your app
but you cut it through the profiler
glass to see if it's doing okay cool now
let's optimize and take another systrace
capture I'm gonna change the
implementation of draw time now instead
of using strings I'm using my my custom
formatting is using the same format I'm
using my custom formatting we'll run it
again with these changes and we'll run
it through systrace and see how that
affected my app cool there it is when I
go to the CPU profiler systrace is
chosen for me I'm starting a capture
just a few seconds should do because
there are a lot of frames that happen in
there cool we have it here right
main thread' selected zoom into a
specific frame we have the choreographer
do frame in the framework and then it
goes down to the clock on draw and you
cannot see anymore
the draw time functions because they are
tiny tiny specks down there
each one of them now taking 71
microseconds and the ondraw is 13
milliseconds now
so we did that now I'm still under 60
frames per second because my app is bad
in other places but at this we optimize
one part of it cool and that's systrace
and let me mention again sessions so
remember I said you can go back and
compare well I have my previous sessions
here on the left and we can see the
previous histories run that we did so
here it is I can select it again and
look at the main thread and see how bad
my draw time was and then go back to the
currently running session and you can
keep all of this and of course if you
right-click you can export the trace and
send you on the bar or want to keep them
you can export these things right here
from the session panel oh let me click
this right and that's our app 10 minutes
and that's our integration with sisters
so there is another way of capturing CPU
datum that is through an API in the
debugger let me go to the line of code
here is so I have my stopwatch and I'm
gonna change it so every time that I
start my stopwatch
I'm gonna run start method tracing and
every time that I stop it I'm gonna stop
method tracing I need to import the
debug list and I'm gonna rerun the app
now before this when once you run this
API you had to go and fetch this file
and open it in either any of your
favorite profilers that can open a trace
file but right now if I'm the CPU
profiler and I use my stopwatch this is
what happens so now I'm taking a capture
and the studio profile has detected that
a capture is being taken place and we're
showing you there and when I stop it I
don't need to go and fetch it defined
from anywhere we pull it from the device
and we show it right there so if I start
on a stop and I start under stop all
these captures that aren't actually
overriding each other because they use
the same file on device we're pulling it
and showing showing them on studio so
that's super handy when you want to
profile exactly a moment in time you can
navigate to all of them and you can see
them here in the sessions panel too so
it's pretty cool one more thing we added
in 3.1
another way of capturing CPU usage using
the C++ something to call simple perf
that if you go to documentation in
Android developers dot-com you will find
documentation about simple perf we have
a version of simple perf inside Android
studio and allows you to sample siblings
blast code and see the entire call stack
of your sim to C++ program I'm not gonna
demo that because I don't have a lot of
siblings less cool
so that's CPU profiling and let me know
- the energy profiler now so energy is
tricky energy is tricky because there
are two main sources that use energy on
your phone well the screen is obviously
I'm not even counting screen the screen
is bad it uses a lot of energy but the
user is using the phone so if you're
using a game right it's all the time
using a screen but the battery drain
problems usually happen when we use CPU
or network when the user is not aware of
this or maybe when we as developers are
not aware of this so let me go live I'm
using a fair amount of CPU on on this
app and if I go into the energy profiler
we classify this as light use of energy
we will show you here things that this
is a theoretical model right so we show
you things that represent how much
energy you would be using on modern
phone
I'm not refining how much energy the
emulator is using obviously but this is
to for us to see okay I'm doing well or
I'm not doing well I'm gonna show you
some things that show up here but
obviously the two big factors are CPU
and network and it's not you know the
obvious thing is okay just don't you CPU
and network but how right I am I using
that in the field and the problem is not
actually when we use it is the problem
is that we don't know we're using it so
let's say I have a wakelock that runs
runs amok and we don't know where it is
and that's using CPU or I have an alarm
that I didn't set up correctly and that
is called it's waking my app and I'm
making Network requests so it's not
about the actual energy is about all
these things that you could be doing
incorrectly that could cause battery
drain in the long term but this is part
of what I was saying before that if you
look at your app if you look at my app
seems to be running seems to be fine if
I were to push this up to the Play Store
and you install it on your phone this is
gonna be the most expensive battery
speaking clock you ever have on your
phone I'm gonna drain your battery right
and I don't know it when I've seen this
so by looking at the profilers we can
see that constantly this is draining CPU
and we can start investigating why like
I said the common mistakes are I have a
white clock that I don't release or I
have an alarm so we wanted to give you a
window so you can see these things
happening the same way if you have a
label in the wrong place you can see it
we want to show you if you have an alarm
that you didn't cancel or you have an
alarm in the wrong place and we're gonna
show you that so let me show you this
piece of my app where I have a timer so
here I can run let's say a 10 second
timer and you can see at the bottom of
the energy profiler that there is a
yellow line that
and pull the tooth tip on it that's an
alarm or a job we show you both there
and you can see that when the timer
stopped the alarm went away and if I
start the timer again again I have the
alarm and this actually when I was
developing this was useful for me to see
okay
am i doing it right when I stop the
timer that's my alarm go away when I
started again do I call it back so this
allows you to see this please don't use
alarms for ask for a timer on a clock I
also have a wake lock on my stopwatch
again don't use wake lock for stopwatch
and you can see that when i started i
acquire a wake lock and when I stop it I
let it go and I can see that it's
working fine if the redline keeps going
I have bug right my app will look the
same and I would ship it and people will
have problems but you can see it through
this window that way is fine or not and
we also track location so if you are
acquiring location like I'm doing now we
have this purple line that shows you
that your current location the emulator
has a really handy feature that you can
actually tell it when to send a location
event so in our model we show you that
that is actually using energy and again
you can see it in the purple bar and if
I stop it
there we go the purple bar is gone but
more than that as you are using our used
to in our over filers we can select a
range and we can show you that you had
an alarm that you had a location request
if I move back we can select the weight
look and do it in a second more than
that I can show you where the location
was required which kind of provide I'm
using a GPS provider so we can see that
we can see the interval times that I
chose where in the code I triggered it I
have a toggle location that happens when
I click the button and if I click on the
alarm not only I can see when I sell it
the first time but when I reset it when
I cancel it so you can see all the
places in the code
that that was triggered so I can debug
problems when this is not happening
correctly let me go back and show you
the the way clock is right there
I select you can see the wake log and
you can see every time that I started I
stopped the stopwatch
I was acquiring and releasing the wake
lock and you can see all the call stacks
Portland when that happened so this is
the power of this this is not to say
okay you're using a lot of battery well
yeah I'm a game I want to use battery so
it's fine the power of this is so that
you can see that your app is doing what
you think is doing it is not you should
go and fix it so cool that's the energy
profiler let me show you one more thing
that I want to show you on the Left we
have the sessions panel and let's go
back in time I can stop a current
session like this and then you can click
on other sessions and we can start
comparing all the captures that we did
back from when I started the talk here
and this was the first time we run it
and we keep all this information until
you restart studio so you can compare
runs and let me show you the last thing
and I want to close with that I'm gonna
close a few minutes early
all right like I said before I'm
rendering every frame I'm doing
something that I should not be doing
that is I mean validating the view all
the time and that is using a lot of CPU
so let's go back to my activity where I
have the code but that's it so I have my
model that I update every frame and then
I invalidate all the time my model has
the ability to know when it has changed
so I'm only going to invalidate the
canvas
whenever something has changed and we're
gonna see the impact that that has on
energy CPU and
right in the app again there we go
you can see now that the energy profiler
most of the time now is below light it
was above medium before we can compare
with previous sessions but of course
when I have to render we can see that
the energy usage starts going up this is
because I'm rerender in my view every
time and you can see the effect here you
can see it on the memory profiler - if I
go back to the memory profiler remember
that line I was going now above ambient
air was collected that is gone I do have
some objects that are being created and
they will be claimed later like here but
it's not as it was before cool and let
me stop the demo and go back to the
slides thank you
[Music]